guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
who recorded this then was it you or the
other sister maybe
30 seconds into them talking so they
approached us and they kept saying
hello um we want to try halal so we
obviously assumed they meant we want to
go to a halal food place
you're harassing me you're harassing me
to a point where he was like i want to
sleep with you why won't you like let me
sleep with you and i was like go put a
headscarf on your mum and then sleep
without i feel that
you said that you feel when muslim men
come and say to oh mashallah this that
you feel rubbish about yourself and
you're like oh am i doing something
wrong
oh is it the way i was dressed oh is it
this why do you have to feel like that
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
assalamualaikum and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are wearing shadow
welcome back to my channel
today we've got um an interesting video
we're going to react to
and we're going to be actually reacting
it with the three sisters
who actually were sexually harassed uh
this is an ongoing problem i've
actually tackled this issue i was here a
couple of weeks ago when i was driving
past
um barking but i'll get into that and
show you in a minute uh first i want to
invite the sisters inshallah salaam
alaikum sisters
how are you guys doing okay
[Music]
that's good okay sister so what i want
you guys to do inshallah is
obviously you're gonna there's three of
you guys there no i'm just two of us my
little sister wasn't feeling too well
she came back from okay
she couldn't come that's fine no problem
so there's two of you guys there uh but
your sister was there but she's not
feeling well
okay so what a video talking
that's fine so what i want you guys to
do as well uh do is inshallah
if you can run me through the day like
for example
um what was your plan on doing um
what was your plan on doing and
building up to the point of what
actually happened
um so initially we had a plan to meet up
just to go out um and get drinks uh
so with ramadan coming up we thought
it's better let's meet now because it's
gonna be harder later
so it was just literally an innocent
advantage to go and get drinks
um and maybe just go for a walk which is
what we did
and we parked up near marble lodge
and from there we went for a little walk
and then we decided
that let's take some food home um just
just a takeaway just something we can
all go home and eat
because we didn't um really have that
plan so it was kind of spontaneous so
the plan was just drinks but then we
decided to get food later
before we went home um so we went for a
walk through
um uh through bond street and towards
oxford street
and we saw some other sisters um
along the way as well they look like uni
students but they were hijabis
yeah okay so we saw them and
we asked them if they knew if there was
any nice um or anything
place like food place especially halal
for us to eat
or like to take away home and they
advised us to go around the sides
towards regent street uh where
um carnaby is it i think it's carnaby
street
towards that way um so they told us if
you got that way there's a lot of halal
places over there
which you can eat so we because at this
point we were thinking let's just leave
it and go home but then because they
said it's just around the corner
we thought let's give it a go and to
mention burglary and a few other places
so we started walking that way and
whilst we're walking
just on the corner between oxford tree
and regent street as we got there
um there were two men that started
approaching us one of them was
really really tall we didn't manage to
get catch him on the camera
um he could have been anywhere between
six and a half to even pushing seven i
would say
and he had long black hair and it was
just open
his eyes were rolling back but we
realized there was something wrong with
them just
maybe 30 seconds into them talking so
they approached us and they kept saying
hello um we want to try halal so we
obviously assumed they meant we want to
go to a halal food place
so we responded saying well we're not
we're not 100 sure
uh maybe if you go that way towards
where are they sorry i was on mute
i was sorry i was thinking why yeah were
they muslims
no no no one of them was uh he looked
black
and the other one looked asian like
chinese and mixed
so um both of them approached us and
they were talking about halal and
obviously like we wanted to go and get
halal food so we thought they wanted to
get halal food as well
so we're like we're not from here but
you can try um tinsel town
and then so we left out that but then
they carried on like following us and
then we thought
what the hell like they we could smell
that they weren't
um it's like as if they were drugs yeah
they really like stumped and so we like
tried to keep our distance
and we were like just try like try going
there and don't follow us like but they
kept following us so we tried to like
leave that place and we were walking
really fast like they could tell that we
were
we were scared comments as
they came and said we want to try halal
and obviously you guys fought obviously
they're talking about
food yeah but but then they proceeded to
say oh no like they were making um
hand gestures of headscarf and they're
like no no like
i wanna try halal and then they were
pointing at me and at that point
obviously like where i come from like
being an afro and women are very um
strong-headed and like vocal about um
how they're treated so i i couldn't take
that i was like how the hell was he
thinking like that about me
and as i tried to like turn back around
and i was trying to like say
how dare you say that my little sister
obviously she was scared
and you can tell from my voice i was so
scared i was so
so scared because of the things that are
happening um
around us and obviously like you think
that nothing like that can happen to you
but
when you're in that moment all those
thoughts come back
flooding and my little sister trying to
um pull me away
and she was like let's let's go let's go
and um
we were trying to like go and then we
changed our route yeah we changed our
route
we went really fast so like we can lose
them
and my friend said that oh let's go with
that couple they looked
um i think they looked arab so we were
like okay if we go with them they won't
if you because we wanted to go back and
forget about walk forget about
the food we just wanted to get to our
car and uh
so basically they ruined your whole day
yeah they ruined your whole experience
basically yeah well
you guys just wanted to go just chill
with the sisters go eat
um and this this and this is
you know we live in the west where you
know some people would be looking at
this and be like
oh it wasn't that deep in that context
you know they didn't touch you that
but if you think about it's actually
it's very disturbing you know because
at the end of the day why would you have
to
feel as if though you know threatened or
even if not threatened
why should anyone have a damn right to
approach you guys
in any way shape or form you know
exactly
and there were people that said why were
you out at that time
well it's it's it's a society for both
men and women like we can
we shouldn't be able to we should be
able to
go out and not be questioned why were
you
like you know how yeah you know how
people
question all the way she was dressed we
were just completely like we were
covered from head to toe
but for them to like have the audacity
to say that it's just
disgusting to think that someone would
justify things like that
and it made us it made us rethink they
they call this a civilized society
those people the way they were acting
and the way later the police how they
were
um so calm about not calm but so
casual about it and the police lady goes
to me oh i have been
harassed as one i was like oh this is my
um authority and if they are like
okay with their who do i turn to who do
i go to
okay should we do this here let's let's
watch 19 second video
and then we're gonna elaborate a bit
more yeah so this is where so what
happened
so he you guys didn't record it and then
who recorded this then was it you or the
other sister
it was me um so what happens is because
this is probably the fourth or fifth
time
that he was now approaching us and
following us that i decided because the
thing is
my phone battery was around two percent
so i would have called the police there
and then but now i was worried if i
called them and my phone dies then
i've got nothing so i thought let me
just make a video like a clip of what
he's doing so i managed this is the clip
that i managed to get
okay so all right let's play this and
let's see what's happened
do you really want me to tell the police
why do you want to talk to me
okay i said no i said no
you're harassing me you're harassing me
how am i laughing you're harassing me
i can i can sense like the kind of
trauma in your uh
voice like um i think would happen
right we'd be right if i said that you
didn't like
looking back you're like wow did i
actually say that do you feel like that
i didn't show like i was so it did deep
inside i was so scared i was shaking but
i didn't want to show him that like i
could not be weak
in that moment but as soon as he as soon
as we got into the train i broke down
both my sister and my friend though they
were obviously scared as well but
because i confronted him so close to me
he was very close to me
as you can see in the video and i was so
scared because you know how
um acid attacks have been happening and
he had a backpack on him
i was so terrified and in that moment
all those thoughts come to you even more
so
obviously i wasn't trying to show it but
i was so scared and when the police came
like my eyes were so red even though
they came like after an
hour i was still in that state of
utter it was disgusting it was
everything
that was not like i couldn't express it
to them and the
the police lady kept asking me tell me
in detail
all the things he said and i couldn't
begin to like tell him i i was
i was just and i was so shocked that i
couldn't um
repeat what he had said and obviously my
friend and my sister were there and they
had
heard all those things that he had said
and to a point where he was like i want
to sleep with you why won't you like let
me sleep with you and i was like go put
a headscarf on your mom and then sleep
with her if you're that
desperate and obviously they they
thought i was funny and i wasn't trying
to be funny i was just so
scared i was genuinely so scared yeah
because they kept saying that oh we want
to know
what's under all that clothing we want
to know what's under the headscarf and
that's what we want to try because we've
never had it before
that's and that's how i mean and some of
the stuff i can't even begin to repeat
yeah and the way they were speaking they
had smarts on their faces and
it felt like they were scanning me
through my clothes you know like it felt
like they could you know almost imagine
me naked and i
hated that i hated i wanted to be like i
wanted to be our home at that point
and you know the thing you touched upon
someone you said that one people would
be like oh why you guys
out at night or some people say you
didn't have the correct hijab
to be honest islamic name you can't
really
like say that okay you know why are you
out it's it's
you can't say oh it's it's your fault or
et cetera
you know because at the end of the day
you know it's a public place
and it's not like you're going to a
specific area where there's drunk men
etc you know we know how across the
street can be but the thing is we're not
talking about a very specific area where
there's
just drunk men and what they do is just
harass women and
you walk on that like you came trying to
say so i don't exactly
exactly yeah don't feel like oh it's my
fault
and secondly for example uh you
mentioned that you was dressed correctly
yeah
the thing is islamically you know this
is really important because sometimes
people have this concept or think that
you know because islam
tells a woman to dress in in a modest
way and a man is well
uh but a woman is very distinct so for
example whether hijab and abaya et
cetera
yeah and you know still in this time
some sisters you know
with a hijab etc they might wear tight
clothes or they might be since we don't
wear the hijab
or there might even be women who wear
they might be muslim women that dress up
outright inappropriately the thing is
with a with the
an alaska panel with toilet tells the
believing men to lower their gaze first
now what that means is is that as a
muslim man myself
how you're dressed like you're dressed
because allah tells you to
yeah um and you're trying to please him
you know um
because then there's a whole
misconception about you know i choose to
wear like this not really like
as muslim woman and muslim men we don't
choose like i don't choose
to dress up modestly i'm told to dress
up modestly because allah wants me to
you know i'm trying to say
and i believe it liberates me you know
and there are people that come and say
oh i
choose to dress up in a minuscule and
i'm like not really you've got societal
pressures that's why there's this whole
book i don't know if you've read this
book sisters i highly recommend it's
called beauty sick
um so in this one specifically it talks
about how
women are sexualized to such a level
that they are actually starving their
self oh you know it's ramadan and with
fasting yeah
there are clothes that are fasting and
when i mean fasting they're starving
themselves
to have the perfect body so if you think
about it they're actually starving
themselves to have a perfect body
most of them are not happy with their
body um and there's
if you read this book it goes to in
great detail with studies um
that show that and the thing is it's and
the point i'm coming to is that
regardless as a muslim man myself or
muslim men in general
this concept of oh but she was asking
for
it or oh she was like this was she look
as a muslim man
i don't care if there's a woman walking
naked
i have no right number one to look at
her look at her
let alone speak to her let alone to
touch her or let alone anything
so because allah tells us tell the
believing men and the
women of course but mentioned believer
man to lower their gaze so
of course allah for me the criteria is i
have to lower my gaze and have utmost
respect for any woman and see them as
my sister that has to be the default
position i'm trying to say
and so you should not ever feel that yes
allah has ordered the
woman to wear the hijab etc because the
biggest greatest
weakness for a man is a woman however
that doesn't mean
the just because i have a weakness for
example like obvious gender when you go
back the right way you get married you
know
nobody's saying you know stay single
forever you can get married so i don't
want you guys i wanted to debunk those
two misconceptions off you know
it was out it wasn't as if you guys were
out at 1am or 2am and
you know in a nightclub place you know
you was there to break you if that it
got dark
etc okay you're going to eat number two
you shouldn't feel guilty for that
number two
uh the way you're addressed even sisters
were like even if you came to me and
said baba ali
we don't wear the hijab or yes maybe i
was wearing a bit of attack clothing
i would say sister this incident
irrelevant i would just say sister try
to get close to allah by wearing the
hijab
i will not say oh sister see if you were
the hijab this
what i'm just trying to say is these men
are doing this because at the end of the
day you know what it is and what it
shows me
is that for them to say this and you
know it's it's it's popularized in the
context where because
a lot of girls in today's age sadly
because they're systematically
sexually objectified i've done a video
like a couple of weeks ago where i was
driving past barking
and and there's banners then you just
you know sometimes you just tend to look
at banners
just come and go there's different
different banners and one of them popped
up of a blonde girl
and she's the marketing a metal metal
company it's a metal company
it's got nothing to do with it she's a
blonde girl and she's got chili in her
mouth
and she's like red hot deals or
something like that
and i found that and i was like wow this
is the reason why
women are so this you know degraded
because
the more you're making a woman like
because
the perception is as men look we we we
have a weakness towards opposite gender
yes
but when they're sexually degraded
objectified systematically on tv
in the books in the magazines on social
media
on banners and wherever it may be what
men
are registering in their head and there
was a study done a couple of years ago
where
they showed men and women in bikini
and they were they had obviously things
in their head um to
um see what part of the brain lights up
and i don't know if you guys heard this
but the
part that lit up in the brain was the
same part is that is
useful tool you know like screwdriver or
i don't know it might be scissors or
so he actually didn't see her as a human
being
so the thing is that's crazy that means
that
these men these men like this are
walking around
and they don't even see you as human
in their brain because they watch
pornography and
and and it's clear what the industry is
about
they don't even see you as a co-human
being
all they see you is a sexual object so
much so that this
vile disgusting man is saying oh
honestly what's under hijab because
they're bored of the old all the girls
show their body what's different
muslim girls they cover up that's
interesting that's challenging
because the challenge has not been left
in the context where you know
um this girls are just dressing up how
they want like you know it's
half naked whatever it may be and still
doesn't justify for people to harass
them but what i'm trying to say is
they see that as a sign of maybe she's
interested
i'm trying to say and cat calling them
done you know after this
girl who got um killed and murdered you
know by a police officer do you know
that
did you hear about it yeah yeah so you
know
um yeah like it's it just shows you and
there was a study that
there was a uh uh research done uh where
they found that nearly
when they corrected it was 91 or 93 of
women
admitted that they were sexually
harassed obviously they said the correct
numbers were 80
87 or 80 percent yeah i'd like to add to
that
everyone's so busy that they just don't
um don't report it and
we didn't want to let go because there
were so many young girls from university
as we said
uh going back and forth on those streets
and they said that there's no cameras
so for them we wanted to report as well
um what do you what you know what do you
think is the reason
why like if you want to add on like why
do you think
men are behaving like this what do you
think the cause is
um what the the the one that's
approaching me or the man
in general like the stuff that i
mentioned like you can agree with that
or if there's anything you want to add
on this obviously because they don't uh
you know how jihad with nafs is held so
so upheld in islam and even our muslim
brothers they
in today's society they've forgotten
that the
striving and struggling from within it
starts from within
but obviously everything that's um
being fed to them and how they're
exposed to everything
and women being objectified and they
only look at their moms and their
sisters with a respectful
um view so so the fact that they um
they didn't step up i think it's because
maybe they thought that
it wasn't our business and she's not my
mom she's not my sister so it's none of
my business so they
just carried on was that muslim met
men walking doors all of them yeah most
of them are arab
yeah young girls guys um
it was a mixture of people families were
walking fast but no one
literally said a word um and in relation
to what you were saying
um like what for example what you saw in
barking and the picture
that you saw um is i think yeah you're
right because the thing is even
little things like this these they're
degrading women and then
you'll have men like like these ones
that approached us who think it's okay
or this is how you're supposed to treat
women or this is how you should be
talking to women um
i don't think they think it's okay but i
think they think
they can get away with that because
mostly they can
yeah yeah exactly you know um
yeah well i it's what message would you
give to muslim men that are listening to
this you know
like because sadly a lot of muslims as
well you know
men as well sadly you know they they
should know much better you know when it
comes to these
things and you know there is like if
like you know i discussed this in my
marriage documentary you know i know
it's a bit late five years late six
years late
but uh the thing is it's sisters is that
you know i i had like moments when i was
looking to get married as well for
example i do ask like i have a specific
moment with muffy
and i say okay if i was to see a sister
in public let's say i've just
all just came to see about you know
there is an islamic etiquette of
approaching someone
you know what we're seeing is that if
somebody was interested in a sister
there is
obviously it's better you know if you
have your sister to get your sister
approached but
you know and these things these things
do happen you know let's be real it does
this happen
there is an etiquette you know there is
a way you can approach somebody in a
respectful way and not sister
you know i'm not coming with the
intention that if i'm in like
can i speak to your father there is an
added sloop um
to things how it can be done and i know
there's a pros and cons to that you know
because i didn't they is a total
stranger you know
and the times that we live in uh of
course there's a lot of cons as well
and there's pros as well and as long as
it's done in islamic according
in a nice way where the person's
intention is not that anyone's with your
father that's our discussion
in itself but what message would you
give to muslim men
who are just outright disrespectful of
you know even salaam alaikum in a
flirtatious way
or like oh masha'allah what message
would you give them because i've got a
message to give them about coming from
you guys what would you say them because
they're going to be listening to this
yeah i think they think it's it's a joke
or
it's not that deep but for us girls it
makes us think how we
how how we are like it makes us doubt
and question the way we
um present ourselves and the way we
carry ourselves when most times it's not
even our fault
but what you said about getting married
and being young
i think because society puts so much
pressure on
young men that they have to attain a
certain lifestyle have a job half a
house
it's not easy most of the times but
obviously allah says
that um it all comes with um
it's all gonna come to you so if you
wait on it
how long are you gonna wait how how many
years how many
years till you know that you're
financially stable obviously it's a good
attitude to have to have goals to have
um
something to want but um it's
not realistic and obviously um
how um i was gonna say um
that is easier for them to have
girlfriends it's so much easier let's be
realistic
even muslims in today's day and it's so
much harder to approach the parents and
like speak to them and then get the
whole
um marriage started
but that's the thing you know it wasn't
an easy way out
yeah but the thing is this is you see
that's the reason why this is one of the
biggest problems that we have in
relation to the question that you asked
um just one more thing that i'd like to
add to that is
like to say to these especially muslim
men
is that you'll always see that they will
be the same men that will be really
protective
of their own sisters yeah but they think
it's okay to
um make derogatory comments
towards other um other muslim women
well as long as okay that's not my
sister it's okay for me to talk to her
like that but oh but if it is my sister
then that's a problem
yeah so my message to them would be to
have the same approach to other muslim
women that you would have with your own
sister as well
exactly you know what one thing they
don't realize is that and this is
it's it's it's corruption in the land
because if you think about it
well the thinking process is very stupid
as well because
it's like you will go and do that to
somebody else's sister or daughter
or mom or whoever may be but what you
don't realize
what you don't realize is that what if
there is
if there are a hundred men like you that
is being done to
another one another person sister and
mother and
if there's a thousand men like you or a
hundred thousand men like you
your own mom and your own wife and your
own sister is going to be
prone to someone like you so what they
do is it's a
that what they're doing you know you
know it's going to come back to them
because
if men all behave like them then it's
going to be it's going to happen to your
mom your sister
and i think one of the reasons why and i
was talking about the bitcoin of um
you know dating you know if you think
about it it's popularized like you know
get to know each other today
it's the biggest one for females because
you're going to be in a relationship
there's no commitment whatever
commitment like you perceive is coming
yeah okay
there's no marriage it doesn't speak to
your family yeah
um it can manipulate you yeah and i know
that woman that many play men as well
um use it for sexual desires yeah if you
think about it the guy's got no down
responsibility like
i if you think about it i'm thinking no
doubt
like there's no i understand not
understand
but if you think about why would he get
married you don't need to pay for a
wedding
no need to pay for mahara don't need to
see your brother or your dad
because they might you know see right
through me i get what i want
it's a win-win situation so that's the
reason why
that's the reason why men muslim men as
well
they're going down that route if every
muslim
let's say sister or whoever may be if we
if our sisters know their self-worth and
i always say that you know i always say
you know you guys are worth more than
being a girlfriend
if every because if you think about if
every woman said no you have to marry me
men have no choice but to marry but
because that's not happening
and those options are there they're
thinking forget that marriage
family that's long so i think that's one
of the reasons and that's why you can
see the corruption in society
how it has a domino effect across board
to everyone i'm sorry that you guys have
to go through that and may allah
subhanahu wa
you guys inshallah um and yeah i really
you know appreciate you guys taking uh
coming here inshallah because it's
important you know with this kind of
stuff
um i like to have sisters have their say
on the matter
because you know how you felt i don't
know i can do a reaction video
and just talk and just oh this is wrong
etc but to hear firsthand from you guys
and how you felt and even hearing your
voice there where you know it seemed
like you was really scared
you know i just want people that's
watching this at home especially our
muslim brothers as well
you know to really understand and know
that you know respecting a woman
is not based on how she dresses um
or she's on it or she if she's on it who
cares oh she's if she's moving like a
you know i'm not gonna mention the word
whatever it may be or she's
this they even made a term like
something jaby yeah i'm never going to
mention it here
so it's these these are not valid
reasons for you to be like
oh she wants to uh she doesn't mind
having intimacy
um so i'll treat you like that that is
that's actually disgusting as a believer
as a man yourself i don't care if that
woman's
whatever she says oh she's only she
wants to whatever yaki you need to feel
a lot you know because
because it only defines you your actions
define you
know what she's doing yeah and so much
so that you what you said one of the
things and i'll end on this is that
you said that you feel when muslim men
come and say to you oh mashallah this
that
you feel rubbish about yourself and
you're like oh am i doing something
wrong
oh is it the way i was dressed or is it
this why do you have to feel like that
why do you have to feel as if it's you
why is it you why is it not them
so the fact that you feel like that is
problematic he should feel the shame he
should be thinking
i made a feel like that not oh like we
shouldn't have this
perception of you know and and once
again there has to be a balance as well
you know what i'm trying to say
because at the end of the day you know
there was a comedian that i was watching
and this comes from
you know dave chappelle yeah okay so
basically
i i used to watch some of his stuff
before yeah but he said something
um interesting and i want to give it
context where
he would say for example some girls say
for example just because i'm dressed up
in a miniskirt or
really revealing everything um it
doesn't mean that i'm a
prostitute now he gives his analogy he
says it's like
it's like my house is on fire and i see
someone walking down the road
and they are dressed up in a
fire man's outfit or oh no he says
police officer he says imagine
somebody's robbing me on gunpoint
and i see somebody walking past and he's
got a police uniform on so i got office
officer can you help me i'm being robbed
and the man turns around this is a bit
funny he goes excuse me just because i'm
dressed up as a police officer doesn't
mean i'm a police officer
the point he's trying to make here is
that
if women are dressed up in a certain way
yeah
in in a certain way sadly you're gonna
attract
bad attention sadly you know and i'm not
saying that's across board because we
saw that even though you guys were
dressed up correctly
you still had idiots what we're trying
to say is that what islam does is it
says prevention
is better than cure so islam just goes
to the root of the problem
and deals with both the man side of it
by educating them
and tend to feel them low in the gate
and also for the woman
to dress up in an appropriate manner and
i think i'll just end on that
um and may allah bless you guys and
thank you for being on here
um until next time brothers and sisters
hope you guys enjoyed that video and
shout out if there's any comments you
would like to make
inshallah in the comments section and
share this with your friends and family
especially
men in your family inshallah and i'm not
well be careful when sharing i don't
want them to feel like you're indirect
with them
share it with your family yeah just
share it across the board and let people
benefit inshaallah
and that's it may allah bless you guys
and enjoy ramadan and don't forget guys
i'm trying to feed
three hundred thousand uh well i'm
trying to raise three hundred thousand
meals there's a link at the bottom
inshallah please give to that
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh